Okay, I want to add a new attribute to our form.
This attribute is called action, and this controls where a form submits to.
I'll give you an example.
Right now we have our tag form, and it looks like this,
and it has a couple inputs in it, and we have our closing tag,
and this is basically the structure of our document right now.
I'm going to add a new attribute to form called action, and it looks like this:
action equals, and then a URL of where we want the form to submit to.
We can put any URL in here, and when we click submit on our form,
it will send the data there.
Okay, so for your quiz, what I'd like you to do
is add an action attribute to your form element
whose value is http://www.google.com/search.
I want you to type some text in the box, click submit,
and tell me what happens.
Is it nothing?
Does the URL change with what you entered?
Does your browser go to Google search results?
Does it appear as though you've written an entire search engine?